you hear the egalitarian clarion call
everywhere everything should be equal
everything should be equally distributed
we should strive for equity it's like
wrong especially if you're a
conservative wrong what we want are just
hierarchies of competence not everyone's
a neurosurgeon you know if your father
has a brain tumor you probably want a
hierarchy of competence for
neurosurgeons so you can pick the one
that's the best so that he might not die
that's what a hierarchy of competence is
for for the postmodernist there's no
hierarchy that isn't based on power well
because they think the world runs on
power and that's why they're willing to
use power to get what they want because
it's the only thing they believe it but
a valid hierarchy of competence it's God
we need those things man we need the
best plumbers we need the basque
contractors we need the best we need we
need the best carpenters we need the
best lecturers there has to be a
hierarchy of quality not only so that we
know who the best are and to reward them
properly but so that we can reward them
so they keep being the best it's like
kid knoweth if you have a great educator
if you have a great leader if you have a
great thinker you want to reward them so
they keep thinking and they keep
educating so they can tell you something
it's not a reward for their intrinsic
being it's a calculated move on your
part to suck everything out of them
that's valuable as fast as you can
that's what a hierarchy of competence is
for and the idea that hierarchies of
competence don't exist is it's so
cynical it's such a pathologically
cynical idea and it's actually quite
patently untrue because here's an
interesting tidbit from the
psychological literature let's say you
want to determine what the best
predictors are for lifetime success in a
Western society well what would you hope
for
how about intelligence there'd be a good
one let's hope the smart people occupy
more positions of complexity right
because they're smarter would you want
it any other way
ok and then so and that's great the
number one predictor of accomplishment
in Western societies is intelligence
so that means the system works what's
the number two predictor
conscientiousness well what's that it's
a trait marker for hard work
so who kill who gets ahead smart people
who work hard now that doesn't account
for every bit of the difference between
people in terms of their hierarchical
structure because hierarchies aren't
perfect they're corrupt people get to
the top sometimes because they're
psychopathic although believe me a hell
of a lot less than you think
because a psychopath has to keep moving
from place to place because once he
reveals himself as deceitful and
untrustworthy he has to go find new
suckers to fleece so the idea that you
know there's no distinction between a
CEO and a psychopath it's like that's
only made by someone who a knows nothing
about Psychopaths B knows nothing about
CEOs and C has something fundamental
against the entire capital structure
because it's simply not true
corrupt sometimes greedy sometimes
short-sighted sometimes running
companies that are doing their best to
augur themselves into the ground and so
you know it's bad people running a dying
organization but generally speaking it's
not the case our hierarchies of
competence are reasonably functional and
not only are they functional they're
valuable we need to know who the
competent people are and we need to
reward them and even more importantly we
need to tell young people hey there's
some hierarchies of competence out there
like a thousand of them go be a plumber
man would be a good one you know be an
honest one B I had a plumber once you
know it was the night it was the night
before we were putting drywall in our
house we were redoing a house and he had
put in all the plastic piping you know
and I was going to test the joint these
are supposed to be glued together with
his pipe glue right and I said I told
him I had to test the joints and he said
well you don't have to test my joints
they never leak and I thought yeah
that's okay how about if I test them so
I went up on the third floor and filled
the pipes with water capping them in the
basement like you're supposed to it like
half an hour later had two inches of
water in the basement there were thirty
leaking joints that was the night before
the drywallers were supposed to show up
so well so he wasn't particularly
competent that's the point of that story
but even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside where the
drywall would be so it would have been
sticky
through the wall so I spent a frenetic
night you know sawing through plastic
pipe and reglue in joints so that my
hope well so that the dry rollers could
come in what's the point if you're going
to be a plumber man be a good plumber
because otherwise all you do is go out
there and cause trouble we don't need
people to cause more trouble we need
people to solve problems you know and so
you can be a tradesman and you can be to
make a lot of money as a trades person
it's a bloody reliable honorable
forthright productive way of making a
living and there is a hell of a lot of
difference between a working man who
knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you till you listen to
these panderers of egalitarian Galla
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one go try in another
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top you know
slap about uselessly and whine about
your life it's not helpful it'll just
make you miserable
you're not reliable to anyone you can't
help out in a crisis it's like so you
tell young people and this is another
message for conservatives like I don't
care what you're going to do but go out
there and make something of yourself for
God's sake be an honest person and work
and get to the top of whatever it is
that you want to get to the top of you
know and and and and then stand up for
yourself like a respectable human being
and be a bit of a light on the world
instead of a blight you know and you can
tell young people that and they haven't
been told that by anyone now and so the
young men are so hungry for that that
it's it's painful to watch
they're so relieved when finals someone
finally comes up and says hey you know
you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth
concentrate on something for a year or
two you could be a bloody world beater
they think really that's possible Wow
that would be that would be interesting
that might make life or life worth
living it's like yeah it might so why
don't you go do it that's what the damn
universities were supposed to be
teaching people they forgot math I went
to Harvard month ago month and a half
you used to teach there and I talk to a
bunch of students you know and I told
them it's not easy to get into Harvard
you know like you're a valedictorian if
you're at Harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in it so that gets I
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like 5% and believe me not everybody
applies so it's a very selective school
and so why am I saying that it's like
these are high quality kids so I told
them what I just told you it's like here
you are at Harvard like get yourself
educated man read some books learn to
talk learn to think make yourself into
something get the hell out there and
make the world that put you here happy
that you were put there in that great
institution you know and they came up to
me afterwards and said god I wish
someone would have told us that when we
were in our first year it's like Jesus
why didn't someone tell the math for
God's sake it's supposed to be the
greatest university in the world is it
so difficult to figure that out well it
is if that is what you want to have
happen in the university you want to
make cringing meltzoff to whine about
being victims while they're going to Ivy
League institutions Jesus it's pathetic
[Applause]